hey there fellow key gurus this is
Debbie and today we're going to talk
about the Apple MacBook Air 15 M2 the
highly anticipated MacBook Air 15 made
its debut on the 13th of June and it is
now known as the world's thinnest and
lightest 15-inch laptop ever made and I
think that is great because we now have
the perfect weight and size laptop out
of the 13 14 and 16 inch models released
no more backaches and hunching your back
when you're carrying this baby around I
think it's needless to say that apple is
known for the Sleek design and it's an
absolute musket for all you basic bits
we have an entire review on the MacBook
Air 15 M2 and if you haven't already
read the review we've attached the link
below MacBooks are known as machines
designed for creators so today and as a
musician I'm going to put the almighty
MacBook Air 15 M2 to the test and that
is
can music production be done on this
baby do two parts mess with the
connectivity and latency with the use of
USBC adapters mbas are Ultra Portables
and like a Butte and fan so can we push
it to the point where it heats up and
dies will this be life-changing for the
music producers who want a record on the
go so before we get into it this channel
is supported by Brands who help us
improve our videos so stick around for
the sponsored message here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of formant function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
alright we're here at vertac Collective
what better way to test out the MacBook
Air than being in his own Studio hi JL
hello hello can you tell us a little bit
more about what you do in this studio
space we do a bunch of things but mainly
We Do music productions for local
artists who do like producing oranging
mixing mastering all the way to like
Live Events and Geeks and stuff and so
now that we know that he's more than
capable enough to do some production
let's hit the booth okay
I think the first thing we got to do is
do is to decide what music software we
want to use on the MacBook
um my take would be to go with logic pro
because yeah I mean it's the most
compatible with Mac aside from
GarageBand and also if you guys don't
already know logic pro provides a range
of enhanced features for pitch
correction midi sequencing and music
notation it grants greater precision and
customization for each plugin in
contrast to GarageBand where plugins are
primarily controlled by a single slider
and like visual controls logic pro
outshines GarageBand in terms of its
Superior mixing and mastering tools but
for all you aspiring producers
GarageBand is so good stepping stone for
you okay so let's pick out a song we
want to rework okay so what song do you
work on hmm
shall we do like a song for my chemical
kid oh sure
work one of all songs
how about All or Nothing oh nothing okay
let's go
okay so I've got all the files here in
my hard disk so I'm just gonna try to
connect and transfer everything over
okay what are you in the face okay I
need one more for my license and stuff
it looks like you've run out of USBC
ports yeah so oh no what do we do what
should we do
what do we do
oh
thank you Belkin this device from Belkin
has got you covered otherwise it's
something to keep in mind and consider
depending on what you need the trade
offer its slim size is having to Grapple
with the lack of ports so if you need to
attach a few devices to the MacBook Air
this is one key consideration to take
note of for those that don't know
tracking a whole ban would usually go up
to 60 layers worth of tracks just like
this or even more so this is how much of
the CPU is working when there are no
plugins being used pretty much close to
zero plugins are usually the ones that
require the CPU to process of which the
two added in are the soothe and virtual
mix rack the virtual mix rack is a low
latency plug-in good for mixing and even
tracking through it the souff plugin is
a bit more CPU intensive because of its
continuous real-time Dynamic processing
of the track hence it's usually good for
mixing we're hoping that the max M2 Chip
can pull through okay JL so we have a
few tracks in already do you experience
any bottlenecking or I don't know any
latency yeah so far the process has been
quite smooth I'm minutes import the
tracks into logic pro without any
hiccups like it was just straight from
the SSD and so far we've got our drums
guitars and bass everything all ready to
go and how many tracks is that in total
right now is around 33 to be exact yeah
okay JL there's one thing that I am a
little bit worried about which is I
forgot to bring a charger for the
MacBook okay and I'm scared that it will
dip as we record okay let's check it
offers okay right now we're at 95 so
let's check the settings
yeah as of from 345 until now which is
like 4 30. we've only used like five
percent so I'm confident we are fine now
okay so we're going to be going to the
booth right now to record some vocals
let's see how it goes
yeah can you hear me jail yeah I didn't
close the thing first off
should we do the chorus sure
[Music]
[Applause]
live
do like more like like takes on that
yeah
I thought you know it's All or Nothing
remember that honey my voice has really
changed a lot umz needs to find a new
singer
retired okay so what would happen if say
you put in all the plugins onto the
tracks why would it slow down so there's
probably two outcome that happened okay
so if the company is not strong enough
to handle all the processing power so
the project was to stop playing like you
won't be able to play
your music before you play better track
smoothly you could start to hear like
some Jitters and like glitching noises
right yeah so that's not what we want to
do okay so we're gonna put in all the
plugins right now and we're gonna listen
back so the moment we hear any
stuttering or any jittering it means
that it has bottlenecked is that what it
means okay exactly okay okay so all of
vocal tracks are processed right now
okay with a basic compression that you
can stuff it okay
so we can see from the CPU performance
meter here so right now with all the
vocal tracks processed we are currently
at 50 slightly below 50 okay which is a
good thing isn't it it's a good thing
okay I mean this is not a fully mixed
project yet so
but yeah we've got like 20 plugins on 20
different tracks and that's still doing
quite well so would you say that the
MacBook has potential for producers to
record on the go yeah definitely like if
you're just doing vocal production and
like basically mixing this is definitely
like way stronger and yeah you can
definitely handle such projects but if
you're talking about like full-on mixing
that would probably be a different thing
altogether I'm assuming it's the drivers
right that your PC is using so like
what's the thing that helps the MacBook
run so the PCS you can see processing
threads so it's a different uh different
course in the
in the CPU itself so right now the rg4
different threads that the MacBook Air
is actually using to process all the
plugins okay
yep yeah so you can see it peaked at 75
yeah so it's building work between all
four course and so far is sending quite
well shall we take a look at the battery
how much we've got yes we shall call you
at 87 so we started off with 95 I
believe let's take a look at the
settings
yeah so in in the period that we were
recording the tracks we only use like
barely ten percent wow I'm sure we can
go on for the whole day without any
issues but without the charger at all
that's amazing so it is true then that
you can actually take this MacBook
anywhere and record on the go we've
added a couple more layers after this
vocal session and plugins on every layer
with vocals we achieved a little over 50
of the CPU usage which is a lot for the
Mac to take with a professional like JL
at the helm and since we added 28 more
layers of plugins we've clocked in at 75
capacity of the CPU and this is only
with Light Recording and production
again we're not even plugged in so it's
too impressive what Apple has done here
okay there you have it folks we
literally went down to the nitty-gritty
of putting the MacBook Air 15m2 to the
test I think we have a clear winner I
think so far like from what we've done
like we're calling all the tracks was no
problem possessing the tracks was no
problem oh and what more we were using
OBS oh yeah to screen record the entire
process yeah so we're recording the
screen throughout the whole recording
process and it's not really like texting
the computer that much and I feel that
you know with this lightweight design
you can bring around it's so portable
you know for all you aspiring musicians
you know who want to record on the go
this is the perfect device for you to
use I would dare say that the battery
life is pretty impressive as well yeah
the battery is impressed is that you can
even print this out to use it for your
work go back home plug it in record your
vocals and you still got spare batteries
to like watch Netflix or something okay
so I guess it's time to put in our final
thoughts the Mac book error 15 is an
excellent choice for music production
due to its powerful features and
optimized performance its exceptional
portability and lightweight design
enables musicians and producers to take
their music production Studio anywhere
for spontaneous activity yeah I think
the MacBook is like the powerful
processors and program provide the
necessary processing power to do all
your plugins and all your music
production it is really a smooth
performance with like multi checks and
virtual instruments and all your plugins
and stuff also I do want to mention the
retina display provides exceptional
color don't you agree it gives you so
much accuracy and sharpness allowing for
detailed viewing of audio waveforms
plugins and mixing interfaces enhancing
the visual music production does
generous storage space as well not to
mention the battery life is insane it is
so good that you know you can just keep
going on and this is especially
advantages for musicians and
environments with limited power sources
it is a powerful tool for musicians on
the go however we recommend it for light
to medium production work if you're not
going to plug it in even if you do
you'll be straining the MacBook Air
quite a bit for heavier projects we
recommend a platform like the Max studio
anyway JL thank you for showing us your
beautiful studio and for also testing
out the MacBook with us thank you
it's been a long day isn't it
thank you all so much for sticking
around to the end and please don't
forget to follow us on our social media
and please don't forget to like And
subscribe to our Channel because it will
definitely go a long way this is Debbie
this is JL and we're signing off right
now until next time don't forget to geek
out and if you want to see more stuff
check this out
[Music]
[Applause]